divided white house coming to the sudden
realization that crime is bad after
blaming the wave of violence on the
pandemic the administration now trying
to distance itself from outrageous
comments from far left democrats like
aoc and chicago's mayor lori lightfoot
who are downplaying the smash and grab
rampages
i'm disappointed that they're not doing
more to take safety
and make it a priority for example we
still have retailers that won't
institute
plans like having security officers in
your stores we're actually seeing a lot
of
uh these allegations of organized retail
theft they're not actually panning out
like when like these i believe it's a
walgreens in california cited it but
what they with the data didn't back it
up apparently it took democrats spewing
that nonsense for the white house to
finally condemn it
we don't agree we have seen some of
these extremely video extremely
disturbing videos showing retail thefts
and both major retailers as well as
state and local leaders like governor
newsom have identified this as a serious
concern we agree
that's the reason why we have
sent additional support
from the fbi providing additional
assistance
while some liberal prosecutors claim the
crime surge isn't real 12 major cities
are setting homicide records
and the crime crisis hitting close to
home fox news is rebuilding our
all-american christmas tree after an
arsonist set it on fire police and
firefighters responded quickly and
thankfully no one was hurt
all right greg no one likes the tree
more than you did yeah how do you feel
it's a terrific loss in my life yeah
actually it is
it's pretty horrible the tree is is
basically represents the kind of random
violence that is fueled by mental
illness that has become pretty much part
of everyday city life we have abandoned
the deranged and i use the deranged as a
scientific there are criminally deranged
people living on our streets and we're
merely we're part of some weird
experiment where progressives had had
never really thought about what happens
when you allow unstable and dangerous
people into the general public well they
assault women we've seen that they have
they assault elderly women we've seen
that we've seen them assault elderly
asian women remember that was that used
to be a hate crime right is it still a
hate crime because we don't hear about
it there's lots of property damage and
now you see a tree getting burned down a
lot of this crime we know what's causing
it we don't know how to deal with this
problem anymore it has to do with a
change in language under using the
umbrella term of homeless which consists
of a lot of different factions but we
immediately are told to assume
it's people down on their luck
but it's not just that you have grifters
you have junkies you have the mentally
ill you have the criminally deranged we
were sold the idea that the homeless
were just benign families who missed one
month of rent no you walk up and down
the streets of new york you see the
consequences of mayor de blasio's utter
failure in dealing with the mentally ill
we gave his wife a billion bucks to deal
with this we have no idea where the
money went meanwhile innocent civilians
tourists people in times square and
broad daylight are getting their asses
kicked they're getting bludgeoned
they're getting murdered by people who
do not belong in the street and we're
trying we want to get them off the
street because they're dangerous to
themselves as well but we have a
grotesque ghoulish mayor who doesn't
give a flying f so there's only one
solution for this and that is people
have to start suing the cities that
release thugs and the mentally ill onto
the street who brutalize people you know
there's a guy that just beat two women
in new york and he was released
then he went and beat another woman
savagely at night like 9 a.m on a sunday
and then he was let out again and these
are the courts we don't have guns in new
york we can't protect ourselves the cops
only arrive after the crime the only
thing that's left is to go after the
courts to sue the cities and whether
it's a class action suit but this this
stuff has to stop do you think that'd be
effective if people started just
slapping lawsuits on these
municipalities judge
you know it depends a lot of people are
covered by sovereign immunity but here's
the problem
it all lies in the legislature this
whole issue has to do with the revolving
door of justice whether it be the
revolving door of justice as it relates
to criminals or the revolving door as it
relates to mental illness we don't know
that this guy was mentally ill everybody
wants to say oh they're mentally ill are
crazy i think they're evil okay there's
a big difference but he's got two prior
public intoxication uh two prior drug
arrests and one public intoxication
there's nothing that indicates he's
necessarily mentally ill maybe he's off
his rocker i wouldn't climb up that tree
but you know that's just me you got the
legs for it yeah they've got the no not
not anymore but but here's the problem
the problem is that we are left to live
with those who are dangerous to us and
to the community as a judge my power
always stemmed from the ability to take
someone out of society who i thought was
a danger to himself or others it's
called a 7 30 in new york then you then
you can send them to bellevue and then
they can sit there for a while and be
analyzed but the bottom line here is the
left is lying to us and that's why this
is happening when lori lightfoot comes
out and she says there's no crime here
and it's up to the people who own the
stories you're full of crap the people
who own the stores pay taxes and you're
defunding the police you're telling the
police to stand down it's you laurie
lightfoot and i'm sick and tired of
people talking about the fact that you
know what we've got to worry about these
people no i want to worry about the
innocent victims and larry krasner ought
to be beated out of philadelphia booted
out of philadelphia i should say and
recall along with gascone they are
literally killing us and injuring us
how do you feel about all this i mean
that's i i would concur with everything
i am baffled by the effort to downplay
the rising rate of crime and murder
across the country by the federal
government by the administration i i
understand that uh the press secretary
today said well actually the doj is
helping a little bit like i just think
that's pretty weak sauce compared to
what people are seeing when you had one
of the police officers today when the
stats came out about the 12 cities um he
said that it was up in rochester that
this is like a war zone
people are actually seeing this with
their own eyes and i think we need a
surge
to deal with it i think that a lot of
this money that they want to spend and
build back better should be put into our
prison system into the court system if
the courts are backed up or the prisons
are backed up or you don't have enough
prison guards you don't have enough
police that's where i would put all of
that money maybe not all okay but um i
would put a great majority of it there
because if people do not feel safe
they're people are not going to vote for
you if you tell them you're fine
you're [ __ ] no don't worry this is
murder capital don't worry about it war
zone you're not it's not real that's
what larry krasner did in philadelphia
people are not going to vote for them
people are going to vote for people who
say i'll keep you safe and who's saying
that right now
i'm saying
it
remember you're a conservative now that
you're pregnant yeah for one more week
did you read the new york times headline
though about this tree they said it just
caught on fire
well that suv also just plowed through
right
wow yeah you're really coming around i
just read a lot and it was in the new
york times so as it was in my bible um
so eric adams is saying i'm going to
keep you safe
and there are some mayors across the
country and specifically the police
chief so i think are leading
the this surge of making it clear to
people in even higher positions of power
that what's going on in the ground is
not adequate they don't have the support
that they need they don't have enough
police officers who have stayed in their
jobs or who want to answer these calls
because they know that things are not
going to turn out as well for them as
they did before and and we can debate
how we got to this place but i think it
relates back to our conversation from
last week about when we're going to see
the fissures between the da's and the
council members and the police officers
the police chiefs and now the
administration and i do believe that
that joe biden gets this this is how he
talked on the campaign trail he was the
first one to come out about the looting
and to say this is different than the
george floyd protests this is ransacking
stores and just taking what you want so
i'm hopeful that we'll shift more in
that direction and as always because
this is on film this is why this is
happening like this is why people are
going to jail who would might normally
be able to get uh away with it and it's
what's going on with these stores
because you can't say they're not being
looted because it's all on film yeah but
who's going to jail
like derek chauvin i'm saying that we've
had a lot of murders yeah but but the
violent crime that affects all of us i'm
just saying that the phenomenon of being
able to record everything is making a
substantial difference in people's
ability to ignore the years yeah okay
all right well from the reporting the
guy that lit the tree on fire is
probably gonna get out today or tomorrow
because
not a felony arson
what he did it is a it's an offense
under new york law where he has to be
bailed right okay forget about whether
or not he is a tie to the community the
guy's homeless he has no ties right so
how does he do bail if he doesn't have
any money
because you don't need money anymore
yeah you know that's why they have this
bail report
hopefully they take away his lighter hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else